welcome to the david pakman show i'm
farron cousins from ring of fire sitting
in for david pakman again today but
don't worry folks
david will return on monday with fresh
content for you i did in fact confirm
that with him today
so he will be back and i thank you all
for watching this week as i've been
filling in it is a great honor a great
opportunity
thank you to david thank you to pat
thank you to everybody with this show
it's a wonderful wonderful thing to be
able to do and the audience y'all are
absolutely fantastic as well and because
of that i'm giving you a special treat
today
i am actually kicking off this show
with an entire segment filled with good
positive
news
now as we all know
in this
i guess profession if you want to call
it that
we don't get to talk about good things
very often usually it's how things have
gone wrong how things could go wrong the
craziness coming from our politicians
but
and of course we have all of that coming
up later but for right now folks
good
news
and the first piece of good news is that
the fda has authorized the very first
covid treatment pill
from pfizer that they're predicting will
be available
in a matter of
days
and this comes as we talked yesterday as
omicron
has now overtaken become the predominant
strain of covet here in the united
states more than 73 percent of new cases
are omicron and of course the graphs are
going back up we're seeing another
upward curve so getting this treatment
having this finally be available for the
first time
is a huge positive development
in our handling of the pandemic
because let's be honest
we know
that the vaccines are effective
we know that the vaccines have been
preventing people from getting serious
illness have been preventing lots and
lots of deaths
but it's not enough because not enough
people are getting it that's how we end
up with more mutations and more
different variants and of course
the increasing deaths and number of
cases
having this treatment
gives us really this two-pronged attack
against the virus itself
now this treatment the pill called
paxlovid again produced by pfizer the
administration
has already pledged more than 5 billion
to purchase about 10 million doses from
pfizer over the course of the next year
10 million doses is not very much i mean
when we're talking about the grand scope
of covet here in the united states 10
million isn't going to get us very far
pfizer says however they're hoping to be
able to produce between 80 and 120
million doses
within the next 12 months so that's good
that might be enough
so what we know so far
is in the early days
much like with the vaccines
the priority
for these coveted pills is going to go
to the elderly those 65 and older and
those with high risk comorbidities
chronic lung problems asthma diabetes
heart problems so again that's very
similar to what we saw in the early days
of the vaccine rollout
and then hopefully
once that is kind of
under control once we get more
production going it will be widely
available to anyone who comes down with
covet
and pfizer also tells us another bit of
good news they have every reason to
believe that this treatment will also be
effective against the omicron variant
which obviously wasn't a thing when they
were doing their testing
but they believe it should be just as
effective and here's why
it all has to do
with how the treatment itself works
which here it is this from wall street
journal
researchers designed the pill to stop
the coronavirus from spreading in people
by blocking activity of a key enzyme
known as protease and my apologies if
i'm mispronouncing that which the virus
needs to replicate the enzyme is enzyme
isn't believed to be mutated in omicron
which is why pfizer and other
researchers say the antiviral likely
will work against omicron
the authorization comes after
researchers found paxlovid was safe and
cut the risk of hospitalization or death
by about 89
if people at high risk of severe covid
took the pill within three days of
diagnosis treatment was also highly
effective if begun within five days of
symptoms
so what's great about that
is it's not one of those treatments
where once you show symptoms oh no the
treatment's not gonna work no you
basically have a timetable of if you can
get it within three to five days of
first showing symptoms
this thing has a real chance you know 89
chance of reducing the risk of
hospitalization or death
so that brings in another part of this
early detection
people have to know if the symptoms
they're exhibiting
are covered or maybe it's a flu maybe
it's a cold maybe it's something else so
that's where these at home testing kits
come into play
and the administration this week said
they're going to give 500 million
at-home tests
out to the public you know free of
charge you don't have to pay for these
things
um 500 mil we need more we're going to
need more and they need to not just be
available
it's time use your power send them to
people's homes
that's what needs to happen here
sure you're going to have some nutty
people out there that just throw them
out
and we're gonna see videos about it
online but
the risk
is less than the reward
because people have to get that early
detection so they know right away when
they get the sniffles oh this is covid
let me go see if i can get that
treatment pill knock this out and avoid
something far worse from happening to me
so again
hugely positive story
combined with the vaccines we may
finally be on track
to get this pandemic under control
because really
the treatment for it has been the big x
factor
so far up to this point we haven't had
any kind of set treatment
you know it really has been not the
kitchen sink part
but it's been doctors just trying to
keep people alive
and that's great they've done phenomenal
work but we haven't been able to find
something to actually stop the virus
virus excuse me from replicating
inside of the human body until this
treatment
so
this is good news
this is highly positive hopefully pfizer
can ramp up their production which is
what they're hoping to be able to do to
get more and more doses out there and if
this works and of course if we can get
this spread around the globe so that
everybody has access to the treatment
not just us here
if we can do that
we may finally
get this pandemic not just under control
but maybe even eradicated
in the future
second piece of hugely positive news and
i'm not you know what before i even get
into this let me go ahead and say
because this is positive news
all over social media
people are glad about it but saying go
further and i'm going to talk about that
but
the piece of positive news that i want
to talk about now
is that the biden administration
announced on wednesday
they were going to extend
the student loan debt repayment
deadline
meaning instead of payments resuming on
february 1st they are now set to resume
on may 1st they have kicked it back 90
days
giving people more time i guess to make
adjustments whatever it is those three
months mean the world
to people suffering under the burden of
student loan debt
and this wouldn't have happened
and this is really the positive part of
this story this wouldn't have happened
without the push
from the public for the administration
to do this
that's the real positive part of this
story
that the activism worked much like
actually with the covet tests yet a week
and a half ago jinsaki kind of laughed
it off during a press conference of what
are we supposed to send a test to
everybody you know give it to them for
free
and then after push back they're like
okay we're actually we are going to do
that
same thing with this student loan
repayment
people have been pushing them warning
them even economists have been warning
them
you're about to deal a major blow to the
economy taking out roughly 85 billion
dollars from it when these payments
restart
is that where you want to be in an
election year tanking your own economy
putting hardship on your voters
and the administration says okay we're
going to kick the can down the road 90
days
so now it comes to the other part of it
right
cancellation
full-blown absolute cancellation and of
course that is what a lot of people are
pushing for
to be honest that is what i'm pushing
for that is what i want to see happen in
this country
that's what needs to happen
yes i understand all the arguments on
the other side you took out the loans
you're responsible for repaying them
what do we do next we pay pay off your
house
well yeah
you want to get people into homes you
want to get them off the streets you
want to give them the opportunity for a
real chance at a better life yeah you
could you should
so i am all for 100
full-blown student loan debt
cancellation short of that
i'm in favor of biden keeping his
campaign promise which is to pay off ten
thousand dollars of everybody's loans
he did make that promise
it's still on his twitter you can go and
see it yourself he said he would do that
and of course we can talk about the
economic impacts of that which you know
some people that's the only thing that
matters
so i went through compiled these
statistics looked at some old uh studies
from this year earlier this year here's
what we have right now as of today we
have 1.57 trillion dollars in student
loan debt held by more than 40 million
borrowers
the livy economic institute of bard
college used data from 2016
and they found that cancellation of the
outstanding student loan debt would
translate to an increase of 86 billion
to 108 billion dollars on average per
year
to our gross domestic product here in
the united states
information from just a couple months
ago this is actually from the federal
reserve says that those
uh payments
are averaging
200 to 300
per month
that's the average some people pay less
some people pay more
but that's what we're looking at so a
full cancellation
not just ten thousand although ten
thousand would cancel debt for millions
of people
you're talking about giving them an
extra two to three hundred dollars per
month which is what they've had during
the pandemic
that for a lot of people that's like an
extra paycheck
and do you know what people do
with that money
well we know
because the analysis also came out this
week along with the child tax credit
they're using it to pay off other debts
some people are actually able to put
some of it in savings
they're using it to pay medical bills
they're using it to pay housing expenses
they're using it to buy food
they're using it on car repairs
which is something that a lot of people
tend to overlook as a major factor
you know when we talk about those
studies that show that people can't
afford an emergency of seven hundred
dollars or more a lot of those
emergencies either involved in a mere an
immediate health crisis or an automobile
crisis
car repairs are not cheap
and the cost of all of those continue to
go up each and every year
and that becomes a major factor that
takes away somebody's ability to get to
and from work
to take their kids to and from school or
daycare or whatever it is
so that is a major problem so two to
three hundred dollars a month
if we had full student loan debt
forgiveness
would absolutely be life-changing for
these individuals and we have seen that
since march of 2020
when these payments were first paused
so i applaud the administration
for listening to the public
and pushing this 90 days back
personally
i want it all canceled economically
it should be all
cancelled
zero it out
change people's lives for the better
and of course the other side of that
that is certainly would certainly
help democrats politically in the
midterms
look we got to take a quick break i'm
fair and cousins sitting in for david
pakman you can find me all over social
media at fair and balanced
we'll be right back with more of the
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farron cousins in for david pakman
today you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com
farron balanced you can also find me on
the big youtube channel youtube.com
the ring of fire and of course i'm on
twitter instagram and facebook at farron
balanced
so we talked about the good news
in the first segment today
and that may be all the good news we
have because now it's time to really get
into the nitty-gritty nutty
stories
of this week
and one of those stories
we hit on earlier this week when donald
trump announced that he was suing
new york's attorney general leticia
james because he believes or at least
his lawyers attempt to argue
that the investigation into him and his
company in new york is somehow
unconstitutional
yes unconstitutional to conduct your
constitutional duties as investigators
but that's not it
that's not all that happened
because after the lawsuit was announced
donald trump
decided it would be a sound legal
strategy
to issue a statement and openly attack
and mock
new york attorney general leticia james
here is what donald trump had to say in
his statement and this is a long one so
bear with me
tell leticia that she is not dealing
with the cuomo brothers a corrupt
governor in a corrupt state including
your office and others and fredo who did
the governor's dirty work for him
despite many years of investigation that
nobody else could have survived even if
they did things just slightly wrong
yours is just a continuation of the
political witch hunt that has gone on
against me by radical left democrats for
years
this is not about delay this is about
our constitution
you are nothing but a corrupt official
doing the dirty work of your party you
should not be in office
this could well be the reason you were
just rejected by the people of new york
in your inept run for governor you
didn't quit for a higher purpose you
quit because your poll numbers were
atrocious you didn't have a chance new
york got lucky
now
i've never been under criminal
investigation um i've never been
arrested
you know i've never really been on the
wrong side of the law
in terms of things like this so
i don't know
but i'm willing to bet
after working with the best lawyers in
this country for more than 17 years
that openly
and repeatedly
mocking and antagonizing the person
doing the investigating
uh
probably not the smartest legal strategy
out there i'm just i'm not a lawyer
right i didn't go to law school but i'm
willing to bet that's probably not what
you should do and i have to imagine that
trump's lawyers were sitting there after
this statement came out
just probably in shock
thinking to themselves oh my god
oh lord what is going to happen now and
then of course probably being happy like
wait a minute this probably means we get
to work a little bit longer and
therefore you know we'll get paid more
money so hey it's a win for us
but oh my god this is going to be so
difficult to defend now
like i can't imagine that these lawyers
actually signed off
on trump's attack against the
investigator this is the woman who holds
your fate in her hand
you know i'm willing to bet based on
what we already know from documents that
are already publicly available
that she probably has enough information
to at least charge you with something
right now whether it sticks or not is
irrelevant but she could make your life
hell
by go ahead uh going ahead and filing
charges at least for what's happening up
in westchester right we got those docs
we know what you told the city your
property was worth and we know what you
reported on your financial disclosure
forms as president those two numbers
could not be more different
so i think she could go ahead and
probably pop you for tax fraud right now
you know just to kind of get the ball
rolling
and as i discussed the other day you
know about this whole political witch
hunt thing
one i think he knows something big is
about to happen and he's trying to get
ahead of it he's trying to go ahead and
uh
plant the seeds of doubt
with his base with his followers
so that way when it finally breaks he
can say see i told you total political
witch hunt
but the second thing
that already disproves the witch hunt
theory
is that they've they've found some
witches
you know
weisselberg has been charged the trump
organization itself
has been charged
okay those are very real criminal
charges against these two groups so you
can't sit there and try to say that oh
this is all fake nobody listened to it
nobody pay attention
it's absolutely just out to get me for
political purposes well
even if that were true which it's not
the fact that they found crimes
would in fact justify
their political witch hunt would it not
but all of this you know trump kind of
gave up the game in his statement like
this isn't about delay all right so
because of that we now know this is
totally about delay
and i think the delay that he wants to
have happen
is he wants this investigation
one to slow down that's what his
lawsuit's about
so that way after the midterms
assuming republicans when actually it
doesn't matter if republicans win but
after the midterms that's when trump is
likely according to his closest people
to announce that he is in fact running
for president again in 2024
he doesn't want to make this
announcement prior to the midterms
because he doesn't want to be blamed if
things go sideways for the republicans
so if the republicans win he's going to
come out and say listen you won because
of me therefore i'm running for
president if they lose he's going to say
you lost because i wasn't there
therefore i am running for president
then once he announces he is running for
president he is going to try to use that
oh you can't prosecute me because i'm a
candidate
i've got executive privilege again even
though i'm just a candidate that's what
he's going for
wait it out as long as possible try to
delay it
with this ridiculous lawsuit he filed
and of course in the meantime antagonize
the very people
who could ultimately end up sending you
to prison
which again
poor legal strategy but it's trump we're
dealing with so
you know
you can't hope to control him you can
only try to contain him every now and
then
and another thing
that trump might need containment for
is his recently announced january 6th
commemorative
press conference that he's going to be
holding down in south florida
this week
trump did in fact announce that he is
going
to hold this big press conference give a
big ol speech
on the anniversary of the january 6th
capital riot
this is going to be held at mar-a-lago
all
all of the major media outlets will most
likely be there which i happen to think
is a big mistake i think the best way to
handle
this upcoming speech
is to totally ignore it and pretend it
doesn't exist
don't give him the air time
absolutely
do not make him feel important that is
the best thing the media outlets could
do
and the reason they should do this is
because we already know what kind of
drivel he's going to be spewing at us
during this little press conference or
whatever it is you want to call it and
we know that because he basically gave
us his talking points in his
announcement here it is
why isn't the unselect committee of
highly partisan political hacks
investigating the cause of the january 6
protest which was the rigged
presidential election of 2020. i will be
having a news conference on january 6th
at mar-a-lago to discuss all of these
points and more
until then remember the insurrection
took place on november 3rd it was the
completely unarmed protest of the rigged
election
that took place on january 6th
all right
so we're going to hear some more
election lies
maybe he's got some new ones to throw
out there i don't know
you know it'd be great to have a remix
of the greatest hits instead of him just
going out there and playing the same old
songs that we all know so well
but the down playing of the events that
took place on january 6th that's the
real problem
and of course he's doing that i believe
because he's gearing up for a
presidential run
and he wants these people back in his
corner
and he may have already lost some of
them because we have had plenty of
reports over the past year they're mad
they didn't get presidential pardons
they're mad he's not helping pay their
legal bills they're mad that he hasn't
stuck up for them more over this past
year so this might be his way of trying
to atone for that although with regards
to presidential pardons you really
missed your opportunity on that one
buddy
so i don't know how many of these people
are willing to come back to you i know
most of them likely will but some of
them clearly won't
but the danger
lies in what he's going to say
because he's going to as he tells us
here
try to claim that these people were just
peaceful protesters they weren't armed
they didn't deserve any of this of
course you can bet we're going to hear
stuff about ashley babbitt
and how she was murdered by police
officers and
how these blood thirsty cops just shot
her in cold blood and for the record i i
do not think that ashley babbitt should
have been killed absolutely not
yeah it doesn't matter who the cops are
killing i'm against it
so i do think
that ashley babbitt should still be
alive today
so too
for the record
should the police officers that were
there
because that's the part these
conservatives always like to gloss over
they like to talk about ashley babbitt
but we got multiple cops
where's their concern for them where's
the blue lives matter crowd on that
issue
right
nowhere to be found radio silence from
those individuals
and one of the reasons i also believe
that donald trump is doing this
is because he sees the walls closing in
over here with that select committee
investigation or as he hilariously
called it the unselect committee who
burn
no that that's that's childish i could
take that to my seven-year-old and i
promise you he could come back in five
minutes with ten better insults for the
committee
if he wanted to go that route but
the committee's getting closer
the committee is getting closer to
donald trump
the sentences that we're starting to see
handed down for these capital rioters
are getting longer they're getting more
intense the judges this past summer
we're telling prosecutors you're being
too lenient on these individuals you're
letting them off for lesser charges we
can get them on more and we should to
prove a
point but most importantly trump knows
that that committee is getting closer to
him personally
so
he feels the best path forward for him
is to go out there with this press
conference that again the media should
ignore but they won't
he's going to go out there he's going to
lie about what happened he's going to
downplay it he's going to attempt to
rewrite history a year after we all
watched it unfold on our tvs
but he's not doing it to protect the
rioters
he's not doing it because he feels any
kind of sympathy towards these
individuals
he's doing it
to make it seem like a lesser offense
that his office at least
was attempting to overturn the results
of the 2020 election
and of course that's why we're going to
get mostly election lies out of him that
day
you know he has kind of been
amped up about all of that recently
and it is because his administration is
being exposed we're finding out things
because of the select committee
that we likely would have not otherwise
known
we would not have known about the text
messages with mark meadows
we would not have known about the fox
news host reaching out and panicking oh
my god you got to do something about
these people
so all of that combined
has culminated in donald trump feeling
the need to go out there and rewrite
history for all of us and again not just
the history of january 6th but the
history of the 2020 election
we've had the audits we've had the
recounts we've had the signature
verifications we have gone through every
possible step of the process
and the fraud that we have found
almost all of it
rests in the hands of republican voters
still majority of republicans believe
the 2020 election was in fact stolen
so trump will never give up those
talking points
because unfortunately
they've been pretty darn effective with
his republican base
i'm farin cousins and for david pakman
we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show welcome back to the
david pakman show i'm fair and cousins
from ring of fire sitting in for david
pakman but as i mentioned the beginning
of the show david will in fact be back
on monday with fresh content for you
but for now
let's get right back to it of course
one of the biggest things this week was
the turning point usa conference
and as we all know one of the featured
speakers was kyle rittenhouse
and when rittenhouse emerged onto that
stage
it was basically like wwe
right
he had his own theme song that they
created for him so if you haven't
already seen the video brace yourselves
because here is kyle rittenhouse's
entrance
into that turning point usa conference
take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with the clown
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the crowd loved him you heard chanting
kyle kyle
but there was one person that was not
happy about this there was one
conservative
who understood that maybe this isn't the
best guy
to be hoisting upon our collective
shoulders
and believe it or not folks that person
happens to be fox contributor tomi
larin
on an episode of outnumbered
this week
laryn
actually i can't say she laid into
conservatives for
idolizing kyle rittenhouse but she did
question
why they're treating him like a rock
star here's what she had to say
i do think that as conservatives we need
to be a little careful when it comes to
this
i believe we can put up kyle ridden
house as someone who was innocent and
was bullied by mistreated by the media
but i think we should step back a little
maybe not treat him like he's a rock
star or a celebrity
i don't think that's necessarily a good
look for the conservative movement
he did what he had to do he was
defending himself let's talk about
self-defense let's talk about the riots
let's talk about how everything went
horribly horribly wrong that day
but i think we should take a step back
and not make the man bon jovi
but that's just my take she says
of course that's how that's just my
opinion you know
don't don't kill the messenger
here's the thing
she's right
that's a weird thing to say but tomi
lahren is right
and she's right
for several reasons
the first is
what's he done
well let's be honest we all know what
happened
two people are dead kyle ridden house
was acquitted
now we could argue all day long whether
or not you think it was self-defense
whether you think he should be here
but those arguments no longer really
matter okay kyle rittenhouse
faced the jury
he had his defense
we had the prosecutors
defense prevailed kyle rittenhouse was
acquitted that's the end of that so
we're not even going to get into that
but two people are dead and we know that
he killed him the court says it's in
self-defense so we have to accept that
and now he's a hero
like now they're lifting him up they
gave him a speaking gig now i'll be
perfectly honest with you i don't know
what he said
i didn't listen to it i have no interest
in listening to it i don't care what he
has to say
although we do know
that he did say in an interview after
the acquittal that you know people
shouldn't be praising him for this
i guess he's i guess he's okay with it
now
but either way
laryn's point i think i don't want to
put words in her mouth but i think what
she's trying to get at is why
what's the longevity
of kyle rittenhouse
what is he actually doing to further the
conservative cause
so the answer to that question would
obviously be
nothing
not a thing
and of course turning point is supposed
to be about these conservatives who are
out there making a difference pushing
their horrible conservative policies on
us spitting out giving us new
conservative talking points
but that's not what kyle rittenhouse is
he's not a political operative
i mean he's a kid
he's a kid that's now gotten swept up
into all of this
and honestly
i don't think he understands it either i
don't think he knows where he's going
with this
does he have a future in the
conservative movement
does kyle rittenhouse have a shelf life
and that's the big point that tomi
lahren herself is attempting to make
think of it this way
i pointed this out actually on fair
balance as well
um the mccloskeys right the st louis gun
couple we all remember them right
what are they doing now they were
conservative heroes
heck they had a speaking spot
at the gop convention last year where
are they now
are they still these conservative rising
stars i know i know the the guy was
going to run for senate and i don't
think that went very well for him
i don't even know if that's still
happening
because nobody cares about the
mccloskeys anymore
and the same thing will eventually
happen to kyle rittenhouse
you know maybe
you know this gun rights organizations
will try to use him as a poster child
maybe he'll do that maybe he won't
that's all pure speculation at this
point to be honest we don't know what he
will or will not do with this newfound
fame
but one thing we can pretty much all
come to the same conclusion on
is that based on others who've been in
this situation before the fame doesn't
last
the spotlights fade
they disappear and people will forget
except the families affected
who this individual is and they won't
care anymore
and i would like to think that that's
what tomi lahren was getting at
but i also think
there could be a degree of jealousy
there right
and let's face it a couple years ago
tomi lahren was the it girl right
she was the one everybody was clamoring
for she was the one making the headlines
she was the one out there
helping
craft the direction of the republican
party
a lot of people forgot she existed
so maybe
maybe and this is you know to to pull a
lair that's just my opinion maybe
she's a little jealous of having to
share the spotlight
maybe she's a little jealous that the
spotlight's not on her anymore
you know people have moved on
and what's funny about that is i
actually said that many years ago when
she first burst onto the scene
because i have been in this business for
going on 18 years
we have seen them come and go
we have seen the flyby nighters they
make a big pop they make a big splash
they hang around for a bit sell a couple
of books and then they disappear
they fade off into obscurity because the
republican movement
you know this conservative media thing
is always trying to find the next hero
trying to find the next big thing trying
to find the next pretty face in many
instances
and tomy starr is fading
relegated to a
weird show on fox having to appear on a
midday show to
tell people that it's a little
cringe-worthy what the republicans are
doing with kyle rittenhouse
yeah
next stop is hollywood squares maybe
dancing with the stars
and people will have forgotten all about
tomi lahren at that point
and that's i think what really scares
her the most
yes conservatives should not be hoisting
kyle rittenhouse upon their shoulders
but tomi lahren speaks from experience
she knows what it's like
as she knows how much it hurts
when you come crashing down to reality
so the question is who is
the next big star of the republican
party
well there was a phenomenal piece
written this week by a good good friend
of mine cliff schechter writing for the
daily beast the piece is titled dan
crenshaw
is the trumpiest of the wannabe new
trumps
and in the piece he talks about the fact
that sure we've got other conservatives
out there kind of you know hinting at
and testing the waters you got your
nikki haley's of course you got your ted
cruz
maybe they're the ones to take up the
mantle of trumpism here in the u.s
and then of course you've got the really
wackier ones your marjorie taylor greens
and your boberts and your gates's
but none of them cliff points out
have what dan crenshaw has
dan crenshaw
for the most part
is not as openly extreme as some of
those other individuals
he knows how to speak to an audience he
effectively has as cliff points out what
trump had
that charisma
coupled with of course shamelessness and
cruelty
but it's the charisma
it's his ability to play to an audience
much like donald trump did
that is what makes crenshaw so dangerous
and of course most likely the heir
apparent
to donald trump's entire political
movement
you know crenshaw recently did an
interview where he called out the
performance artists
of the republican party
and he told us we know who they are he
didn't want to name any names he doesn't
want to make any waves because he's
smart i'll give him that he is smart
he's good at what he does
but it's pretty obvious that he is
talking about your marjorie taylor
greens and your lauren boberts the
people and madison cawthornes the people
who are out there just to get famous
they just want people to know their
names and as he pointed out correctly by
the way
they're not doing anything legislatively
okay they're not actually furthering the
conservative cause as he says
and his ability to call these people out
and seem
as he's calling them out like the
rational choice like the best
alternative
is what does make him so incredibly
dangerous as a potential candidate in
the future
and then of course
you have the performative side
crenshaw has something the rest of them
don't
he's got military credentials and as
cliff schechter points out again
he's got the battle wound
he's got the eye patch
and i'm not saying that to attack him
but that eye patch is a constant
reminder that he served
that he went over there and fought the
fight
that these other conservatives only push
from behind their legislative desks
that makes a big
difference
with these republican candidates
somebody who can go out there and say oh
well you say you support the military
but i was actually in it i fought it
and i live with the ramifications of it
he's got that tough guy persona that
donald trump could only pretend to have
and of course you do have the
performance artist in him right
we've all seen the videos that
crenshaw's point out uh put out excuse
me
himself you know rappelling down from
the ceilings acting like some kind of
avenger slash secret agent guy this big
tough bravado
of only i can save this
which is kind of similar to what donald
trump actually said
when he first ran for president only i
can do this
and that's what crenshaw is putting out
there
he appeals to the trumpers
but he can act sane enough because i do
think to his credit i think he is a sane
person
but i think he knows when to turn on the
crazy and turn it off and that's what
separates him from the rest of the pack
that's what makes him different from a
marjorie taylor green
it's what makes him different from a ted
cruz because ted cruz has gone full
blown into all of this he doesn't know
who he is
but crenshaw
can turn it on and turn it off like that
and as cliff points out
that's something that makes him
incredibly valuable
to the conservative movement and of
course makes him incredibly scary
as a potential republican candidate
in the future
i'm farron cousins follow me on youtube
at youtube.com the ring of fire and
youtube.com fair and balanced i'm across
social media platforms twitter facebook
instagram at fair and balanced you're
watching the david pakman show
we'll be right back with more
follow the david pakman show on social
media interact with me and other david
pakman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on twitter at d
pacman and david pakman show we're on
instagram
david.pacman join the reddit community
at davidpakman.com
reddit and you can also find the david
pakman show on facebook
discord and tick tock it's almost too
easy
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman i've been
sitting in for david all of this week he
will return to you on monday i promise
he has given me his word
but
let's finish things up here shall we and
of course as i've done every day this
week you gotta talk a little bit about
joe manchin public enemy number one
and now
we're finding out that republicans
including
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
are actively trying to recruit
joe manchin over to the dark side come
to us officially
they're telling him
and that's not hyperbole either
literally it's been reported that john
cornyn admitted
to sending joe manchin a text message
inviting him to come and join the
republican party in the senate
we're your friends you're just like us
come on joe what do you say
mitch mcconnell however
said in an interview with the new york
times
obviously we would love to have him on
our team i think he'd be more
comfortable why in the world would they
the democrats want to call him a liar
and try to hotbox him and embarrass him
i think the message is we don't want you
around obviously that is up to joe
manchin but he is clearly not welcome on
that side of the aisle
joe manchin himself this week
also
talked about the the bullying that he is
receiving from those on the left for
killing the build back better act
and said you know they ought to push me
into the republican party
that's what he said
and i think these republicans took that
as
if they're not going to push you we're
going to try to pull you
so come on joe
and to be honest think about it this way
obviously if joe manchin were to leave
the democratic party go over to the
republicans they get the majority they
take over the committees and all of that
it's horrible
right right
is it
the democrats are already struggling to
get anything done
because they have only 50 and
republicans have 50.
and joe manchin
is the biggest roadblock
now i understand 100
if joe manchin were to leave the
democrats become a republican give them
the majority nothing gets done
you know the voting rights act kiss that
goodbye
any chance of getting a different
version of buildback better
gone
but what are the chances of those things
happening with joe manchin as a democrat
anyway
wouldn't it make more sense electorally
speaking
for the democrats to boot joe manchin
don't give him the option
tell him you're out
and then let the republicans take the
fall for
it the public wants to build back better
act
so if you can pin the whole thing on
republicans if joe manchin were to go
over there
wouldn't that be a better campaign
message
you know look we tried to give you all
these things and it got so bad that one
of our guys ended up becoming a
republican because he hates it so much
he doesn't want you to have good things
so he's joining the party that
continuously refuses to let you have
good things because that's what they
stand for because that's who they are
so if you want these things
we got to get the majority back
now as again i've talked about that this
week republicans have to defend 20 seats
20 seats in 2022
that requires a lot of money
and the odds
significantly reduce that you're going
to hold on to every single one of those
seats the more you have to defend
you also have members who are
considering retirement some who've
already announced retirement so in those
new races of course that's going to be
far more expensive and it opens the door
for a democrat challenger to seize the
seat
so
democrats could probably come up with a
winning message
by getting rid of joe manchin
because again then the entire boogeyman
becomes the republican party
i'm just throwing it out there as a
possibility as a very real electoral
strategy that the democratic party
should at least consider
and if you're not willing to kick joe
manchiman out or not willing to push him
over to the other side
then at the very least don't let him get
his hands on the dnc money when he's not
going to support the democratic party
itself
i mean after all reports have also come
out this week saying that he's receiving
so much corporate cash right before he
announced that he was not
going to be supporting the build back
better act so joe manchin will be fine
hell he's not even up for re-election
for a while
so don't worry about him
kick him out
make him part of the enemy
and see what you can come up with in
terms of electoral strategy
messaging once that happens
you keep him in the party
you're gonna have to deal with him and
his problems and the negativity that he
brings with him
for at least another full year
and to me
personally i just don't think that's
worth it
there what may be however
one way that it could be worth it and
that is if joe manchin agrees to kill
the filibuster
so that democrats can pass the john
lewis voting rights act
and the reason that piece of legislation
is so dang important
is because of the new report we got this
week
according to a new report from cnn
you have
multiple republican-controlled states
out there including some who have
already passed
restrictive voting measures this year
that already have a full slate of
legislation with even more
restrictions
heading our way in 2022
let me read this
lawmakers in four states already have
pre-filed at least 13 bills for the 2022
legislative sessions that would make it
harder to cast a ballot that is of
course according to the brennan center
for justice
in five states six pre-filed bills would
allow audits or reviews of election
results as former president donald trump
and his allies continue to baselessly
attribute his 2020 loss to election
fraud
in addition
some 88 restrictive bills that were
introduced but failed to become law in
nine states this year are expected to
carry over into legislative sessions set
to begin early next year
and let's not forget that so far in 2021
19 states passed 34
restrictive voting
bills
because this is what they do
because this is the only way that
republicans can win
they can't win on the issues
they can't win on economics they can't
win on policy they can't win on populism
i know trump did in 2016 but technically
lost the
popular vote
so what do they do
they do two things they resort to
culture war issues which they've been
fairly successful with this year
and of course voter suppression
keep just enough people out of the way
and we might be able to have a victory
drum up even more support from our
crazed base
with these culture war issues by talking
about critical race theory and
transgender athletes
and we might be able to eke out a
victory
and of course they're helped along the
way with gerrymandering which is going
to play a huge
role in the 2022 elections
the only x factor out there right now is
how many people died from kovid that
would vote for republicans
according to the numbers we're seeing
right now a lot
so
they're going to have to contend with
that
continuing to push anti-mask and
anti-vax viewpoints isn't going to work
out so well for them electorally
so of course
they have to push these restrictive
voting bills
and as i said
one of the worst parts of this is some
of these are in states that have already
passed
restrictive voting measures this year
florida and georgia are the top two
georgia is still trying to go even
further
according to this new report
by
further limiting drop boxes further
limiting
collection of ballots and of course
cutting down on the number of polling
places
in a given
county
florida again i mentioned this earlier
this week they want to create a new five
million dollar office whose job it is to
go around and find voter fraud
which
i mean does exist to a small degree
certainly not in
in enough numbers to sway an election
and of course most the cases we're
finding here in florida are
republicans so that's probably not going
to work out very well for them but
that's what they're doing
and they're doing it because they can't
win
on the issues
they can't win
talking to normal people
so they shut them out they get them out
of the system get them off the voting
rolls by any means necessary
because that is their only path to
victory
they've been hugely successful with it
in the past
and most of these places where these
bills are being proposed
there's not enough opposition
to prevent them from becoming law before
the 2022 election
and finally for this week for me
we got to talk even more unfortunately
about the turning point usa conference
because there's one last thing from that
that i want to discuss that is truly
terrifying and that is madison cawthorne
during his speech
started talking about civil war
and how if we have another civil war
which he swears he doesn't want but if
we have one
man conservatives are totally gonna win
it
here's what he says
we patriotic americans because
republicans hold the monopoly on
patriotism
were born for such a time as this we're
going to face some dark times as a
nation i genuinely believe that i think
we have an opportunity in the next four
to six years to prevent kinetic force
countrymen on countrymen
from ever meeting
although i have no doubt we would be
victorious if that would ever happen but
remember that that would be so immoral
and wrong if we said hey you know what
let's kick off a civil war
and then we'll just go ahead and go to
that point
it's time for us to stop being sheep and
stand up and be lions the radical left
should be terrified of who we are the
radical left should be terrified of what
we are going to do
oh we are
we absolutely are
because we've seen what you do
we've seen what your kind does
they storm the capital
they assault police officers while
storming the capital
they call in death threats
to secretaries of state
because they don't like the election
results of that state
they call in so many death threats to
certain members of congress that they've
had to undergo special training
on how to handle these things
they issue racist and bigoted threats to
them
on the floor of the house of
representatives do i need to go on or do
you get the picture here yeah
that's what terrifies us
it terrifies us that this is becoming
normalized and it's becoming normalized
by people like madison cawthorn himself
also in his little speech there
he encouraged people to drop out of
college
told young conservatives if you're not
going to be a doctor lawyer engineer
just drop out it's a scam he said
he dropped out and he turned out just
fine
yeah so fine by the way
that he is running for congress in a
different district next year because his
current district is turning blue and he
knows he can't win so he has to switch
over to a different one in order to you
know keep his job that he clearly
is not qualified or even rational enough
to be holding
before i go today i want to take another
moment here to thank david to thank pat
thank everybody
with the david pakman show for giving me
this opportunity the week of christmas
to fill in
to be here with you i thank everybody
who tuned into this and of course if
you've enjoyed me
and even if not you should probably
still do this you can subscribe to my
youtube channels youtube.com slash the
ring of fire and youtube.com fair and
balanced you can catch me every week on
the ring of fire podcast
rofpodcast.com
twitter facebook and instagram at farren
balanced i hope everyone has a wonderful
holiday weekend whether you celebrate or
not take some time enjoy it have some
good food relax
and wait for the new year to begin i'm
fair and cousins and david pakken